congratulations on this movie guys it's
absolutely amazing so powerful now BRE
this the first time we're seeing you on
screen since Captain Marvel
since Avengers do you do you see your
approach to things changed now because
people see you as such a role model that
you want to take projects that really
have something to say no like nothing
really is changing your approach to pick
two things no no I mean my purchase at
the same time I just I really care about
what it is that I'm making and I care
about what it's saying but I was doing
that before Captain Marvel ya know I
don't really like there's a lot of
people in the world and so there's just
so many opportunities for people to
project onto me but I don't connect with
that well now I just do it what I'm
doing yeah in terms of Michael B Jordan
producing this it obviously this is a
huge passion project for him what was it
like on set with him incredible yeah
yeah Michael moves in purpose and he
moves I think in a way that reflects
Brian's work in terms of giving a sense
of honor and dignity dignity to everyone
there wasn't a hierarchy he led an
ensemble both in front of and behind the
camera and doing the work and so I think
that he exemplified Brian's spirit in
his approach in terms of yes it's hard
work yes there are long days but we have
a goal here we have a purpose and I look
I'm not gonna tell you what to do and
how to do it I'm going to show you this
is how this is how it's done so it was
incredible yeah it's amazing no this was
like 90 92 that 73 do you think things
have changed now uh I mean that's really
a Brian question like are you asking
like I've lost in terms of like you
think yeah how people are treated how
african-americans are treated in the in
the justice system you think things have
changed in any way in 26 27 years I
think the biggest change is awareness
and I think that's what this film seeks
to do to create an awareness to create
conversations that we may not have
otherwise conversations that may be
uncomfortable I think this film opens
the door for us to have them in a space
of versus we versus them or you know
often Cindy
in a space of we are human beings on
this planet together there are things
that we need to address how are we going
to do it this is how let's get it done
right and yeah for real like for you
what do you want audience to get out of
this movie I'm not in control of anybody
else
unfortunately so I don't know but I will
say that I really I heard this phrase
the other day that I loved so much which
is change moves at the speed of trust
hmm yeah and and so to your earlier
point of how have things changed like I
don't know if enough people have really
gotten to look at the subject matter
enough to see the leaps and bound
changes that we want but it really
starts with looking at and getting to
know these people that we have decided
should be just forgotten and put far
away from our view and really look at
them and create trust yeah we'll sit
yeah congratulations it's absolutely
amazing
you